[Música]
con estás
qué tan grande son tus miedos para ccoo
con lugares los miedos significaron
mucho en su vida
yo me salí de mi casa desde muy niño más
bien escapé de mi casa a los 10 años
por problemas familiares no me entendía
con mi mamá había mucha violencia en la
casa y bueno eso eso hizo que yo
decidiera desde escaparme de irme de mi
casa vivía con mucho miedo y bueno
estuve viviendo las calles de la ciudad
de méxico en el estado de mexico
donde aprendía
a ganarme en la vida no
para lavar camiones vender chicles
vender paletas ser cobrador dormir en
las calles en las centrales camioneras
había momentos donde algunos chóferes me
daban chance de dormirme el camión
adentro pero no pasa tanto frío fue la
verdad muy muy muy difícil vivir en la
ciudad de mexico hoy día lo pienso y no
lo puedo creer lo de haberme salido tan
tan temprano no tan niño en mi día y
después de seis meses es vivir en la
ciudad de mexico y sobre todo decidirme
acapulco no recuerdo muy bien por qué
decidirme acapulco pero me fui acapulco
y en cuanto llegué acapulco rápidamente
conocí a un grupo de niños de un grupo
de niños que estaban cantando y
rápidamente pues hice amistad y les dije
que quería trabajar me enseñaron a tocar
el güiro ya mover la panza
sí porque ellos cantaban a los turistas
a los extranjeros y bueno yo también ahí
tocando el ruido la cucaracha y todo eso
y bueno así empecé en mi historia en
acapulco después estuve
en el área de la condensa en la playa
donde también vendía rosas en las noches
en las discotecas empecé a conocer toda
la gente de ahí todo mundo empezaba a
conocer
también esa parte en acapulco fue la
primera vez que yo tuve contacto con el
mar cuando empecé a aprender a conocer
al mar yo tenía mucho miedo al agua al
mar a los ríos recuerdo cuando era mucho
más pequeño mi mi madre me llevaba a los
ríos a los balnearios y yo me le
colgaban el cuello y lloraba y yo tenía
mucho miedo bueno
mis amigos siempre se metían a la playa
yo siempre me quedaba en la orilla hasta
que un día dije sabes que me voy a meter
me voy a meter y lo voy a hacer siempre
la gente me empujaba a meterme y era
peor pero un día decidí yo solo el no
hacerlo cuando decidí hacerlo
entra y viene una ola muy grande nos
agarró a todos todos los chicos estaban
haciendo varios surfing y todo eso y
bueno nos agarró todos de repente me
encuentro bajo en el fondo del mar no
podía salir alguien más alguien mayor me
agarró y me llevó a la superficie y ahí
todo el mundo me puesto a hablar que me
tranquilizara que empecé a escuchar las
indicaciones y de repente pues me quedé
en vez de salirme y llorando no al
contrario me quedé como que rompí como
que se rompió ese hechizo no del miedo
que yo tenía el mar y el agua y de
repente me quedé y me quedé solo con
ellos y bueno fue para mí un momento
donde yo puede como no sé fue un momento
mágico
bueno y así me la llevaba en acapulco de
repente también había momentos que no
tenía para comer pero ya me conocían ahí
había un restaurante en particular que
se llamaba el paradise y me dejaban
entrar a la cocina por la parte de atrás
y me comían las obras de la gente que
dejaba sus comidas cuando realmente no
tenía que no había ganado ningún peso
para comer y pues ya yo entraba y había
momentos que yo comía de ahí
más o menos como los seis meses de estar
en acapulco pasó un incidente muy feo me
agarró la policía puso la pistola y me
metió un carro creo que eran judiciales
y me llevaron y me interrogaron en un
lugar en un baldío y quería que yo
dijera quienes quienes venían las drogas
quienes robaban y etcétera y pues me
golpeaban
totalmente y yo la verdad yo no tenía
nada que ver con eso si conocía algunos
sabían las gentes los males que estaban
por ahí todo por jon yo no tenía nada
que ver incluso una vez me dijeron bueno
si quieres estar aquí en el área turno
si te llegan a a
tú nunca tú no puedes hablar porque si
hablas te pueden muy mal entonces bueno
me golpearon me tuvieron como tres horas
interrogando hasta que después de un
rato escuché una voz por atrás y dijeron
bueno este cabrón no va a hablar vamos a
matarlo ya y en ese momento cuando me
pusieron el arma en la cabeza
me puse a llorar pensé que se iba a
morir me vi la cruz de la bahía las
brisas de acapulco y empecé a llorar y
tiraron hicieron tres tiros
y después de ahí me dijeron que me
querían ver en el mismo lugar a la misma
hora del día de mañana y se fueron yo me
regresé caminando hasta la condesa a mis
amigos me preguntaron que qué había
pasado les conté toda la historia
pero justo una semana antes de todo ese
incidente yo había escuchado una
conversación de otros chavos que no eran
mis amigos que llegaron justo donde
ellos estaban en un lugar
escuché que hablaban de un lugar de un
paraíso llamado por tu escondido y que
el surfing y las olas y que era
increíble y bla bla bla puerto escondido
por tus con ellos se me quedó en mi
cabeza pues bueno cuando pasó este
incidente yo decidí irme de acapulco
dije es hora de partir no quiero esta
vida yo no quiero estar aquí y compre un
boleto de autobús y me voy acapulco
llegué acapulco las 6 de la mañana al
perdón llegue a portos con ido a las 7
de la mañana
yo tendría como 11 años justamente
cumpliendo 11 años con llegada por tu
escondido me fui directamente a la playa
de zicatela
me quedé en la playa viendo las olas
enormes las olas estaban gigantes y yo
me quedé en la playa sentado así viendo
el mar gigante y nada más sabía cómo
tres personas surfeando y estaban ahí
surfeando yo he agua o yo quiero hacer
eso yo quiero hacer eso yo voy a hacer
eso no y me quedé así horas y horas
viendo bueno después ya me fui a la
bahía empecé a conocer gente he conocido
un amigo y que me ayudó mucho desde
conté mi historia y me llevó al
restaurant de su mamá donde me dieron
trabajo lavaba platos y se hacía de todo
pues para comer y tener una hamaca para
dormir y bueno cuando llegué a portu
escondidos sabía que
qué puerto escondido iba a ser mi casa
por el resto de mi vida e incluso hasta
fui a una iglesia y emprendió una
veladora y le dije gracias señor
gracias dios de poder estar aquí porque
yo venía de la ciudad de méxico acapulco
sí
el peligro una vida diferente y por
descontado un pueblito pequeño no había
no existía maldad no hay sueños de calle
no existe nada de eso yo me sentí salvo
en ese lugar bueno de ahí empecé a de
ahí conocí el surfing empecé a aprender
a surfear
y de la primera vez que yo aprendía a
surfear y que logré agarrar una ola solo
y correr una ola solo hasta la orilla
fue lo máximo
yo me recuerdo muy bien que iba en la
ola así
corriendo corriendo hasta la playa y
recuerdo que está hecho que en la arena
y guayabas y gritando y fue una
sensación increíble que es difícil
describir lo que tienen que hacerlo para
sentirlo no es lo máximo el surfing en
ese momento dije wow sabía que también
el surf iba a ser parte por el resto de
mi vida que iba a ser parte de mi idea y
bueno empecé a conocer a todo el mundo
empecé a trabajar y buscar trabajos fui
el lanchero este pescador mesero hacer
todo para vivir
y ahí empecé a conocer mucha gente
muchos extranjeros por dos con ellos un
lugar famoso por el surf internacional
y empecé a crecer de ahí tuve tuve la
oportunidad bueno me invitaron a ir a
california y yo quería ir a california
más que nada y ahí a hawai por por mi
pasión al surf que ya había había
crecido yo todos los días surfeaba
trabajaba las mañanas y soria buenas
tardes me crucé la frontera eeuu ilegal
lo hice un par de veces simplemente
porque yo quería conocer el mundo más
del sur irma hawai me pierda agua de los
14 años
la gente como en el mundo reconocían mi
historia y como que me ayudaban y así
estuve de ida y vuelta a los 17 años que
me hicieron una publicación en surfer
magazine una de las revistas más
importantes del mundo del surf y me
hicieron una publicación y hablaban de
mí que a temprana edad se fiaba olas
gigantes y que había cruzado la frontera
solo por el sueño de vivir de surfear
las olas grandes y todo eso y entonces
cuando hicieron esa entrevista y dije
guau
yo creo que puedo vivir de esto no como
que si por algo me he publicado no sé
entonces como que de ahí empezó a crecer
más mi deseo no por el sur por llegar
a ser profesional y gracias a esa
revista conocía a unas personas muy
buenas de eeuu que empresarios de marcas
de esos muy importantes que hoy el
nombre es really pero antes tenían
billabong y me dijeron fueron a puerto
escondido con un grupo de profesionales
y me dijeron tú eres el chico de la
revista que sale una entrevistas y dice
te queremos ayudar leímos tu historia y
entonces empezamos a hacer una formación
a una relación de amistad que un
patrocinio al principio y ellos bueno de
ahí me mandaron una carta para que yo
tramitará mi visa y realmente yo cuando
fui la embajada pues yo no tenía todos
los documentos no tenía cuentas de banco
pero pues esa carta en frente y por
alguna razón no sé tuve la suerte no se
me dieron la visa y yo estaba súper
contentos y feliz gritaba porque ya no
que yo no quería pasar de ilegal más a
mí no me interesaba vivir en estados
unidos y trabajar yo quería yo amo mi
país y yo nada más quería ir para
vale ir a hawai surfear y hacer todo eso
nuevo bueno y así me la llevé así me la
llevé hasta los 25 años trabajando
haciendo de todo para viajar hasta los
25 años fue cuando yo empecé en mi
carrera profesional que ya las marcas
ferley ya me empezó a pagar tenía mis
contratos mensuales
después llegó red bull también me
empezaron a ayudar y empecé a viajar por
todo el mundo conocer lugares exóticos
personas
de todas de todas todas partes del mundo
lugares el surf y me ha llevado muy
lejos no tanto como conocer gente
culturas
a tener esa conexión con el mar con la
naturaleza es increíble pero bueno
sin embargo hubieron decisiones que
cambiaron el rumbo y el destino de mi
vida y gracias a esas decisiones hoy
estoy aquí en frente de ustedes gracias
a decisiones he cumplido sueños gracias
a que mi mamá me empujó y fue como fue
estoy aquí gracias a eso yo soy un
hombre muy feliz de poder
vivir y estar viviendo mi sueño de
surfear y hacer muchas otras cosas
pero cuáles fueron esas esas decisiones
hubieron muchas decisiones en mi vida si
me pongo a contarles aquí no terminó
pero yo creo que las cuatro decisiones
más importantes 25 fueron la primera fue
haber tenido el valor de haberme salido
de mi casa a tan temprana edad o hoy lo
pienso digo no puede ser hoy vi dos
niños de diez años y digo no puede ser
yo tenía esa edad cuando no salí de mi
casa la segunda decisión fue haber
aprendido
a trabajar para poder sobrevivir la
tercera fue fueron las decisiones de
momentos de emigrar
desde que me salí de mi casa los
momentos de que decidí irme de
méxico-acapulco de acapulco a puerto de
puerto california todas esas decisiones
cambiando no fueron importante en mi
vida
la cuarta fue cuando decidí cuando
decidí romper ese miedo enfrentar ese
miedo y meterme en el mar yo solito y
decir yo lo que yo puedo yo lo voy a
hacer
la quinta decisión fue
haber conocido abrigado por escondido
haber conocido el surfing del surfing
el surfing para mí fue una herramienta
tan importante fue como un vehículo que
me guío en mi vida que me ayudó a
enfocarme y enfocarme para yo me aferré
del surfing me ayudó a enfocarme para
para seguir mi sueño
para seguir mis sueños ser constante
el surfing fue y es algo muy muy
importante entonces
lo que yo creo que la vida puede
llevarte a diferentes en diferentes
contrastes desde los muy buenos hasta
los muy malos pero justo en los malos
momentos y en las decisiones que tomes
pueden llevarte
pueden llevarte a contrastar de manera
positiva tu vida
pero la más constante es la más
importante es que tus sueños tienen que
ser más grandes que tus miedos
[Aplausos]
[Música]